tormenta Trump el expresidente dijo en
su red social red social que podría ser
arrestado el martes un mensaje que
recordó al que precedió al asalto al
Capitolio ahora filtraciones ilegales de
una corrupta y altamente politizada
oficina del fiscal de Manhattan que ha
permitido que se establezcan nuevos
récords de crímenes violentos y cuyo
líder está financiado por George soros
indican que sin que se pueda aprobar
ningún Crimen y basándose en un viejo y
totalmente desacreditado por numerosos
otros Fiscales Cuento de hadas el
candidato republicano más importante y
el expresidente de los Estados Unidos de
América será arrestado el martes de la
próxima semana protestas recuperen
nuestra nación un gran Jurado de Nueva
York que Investiga los presuntos pagos
de Trump durante la campaña de 2016 para
silenciar a la actriz porno estormy
Daniels y a la modelo de Playboy Karen
por un total de 280 mil dólares pagos
registrados como gastos legales sería el
primer ex presidente en ser acusado de
un delito esto podría afectar carrera
presidencial
el Cardo que puede presentar El fiscal y
que parece que está a punto de presentar
es que Trump falsificó los registros
comerciales de la organización Trump lo
cual es criminal en Nueva York si
falsifica los registros comerciales de
una empresa comercial Entonces está
sujeto a una sanción de al menos seis
meses eso es un delito menor pero si lo
hace para ocultar otro delito Entonces
se convierte en un delito grave y eso
puede darte una sentencia de hasta 4
años que es un impacto mucho mayor
Trump también enfrenta investigaciones
criminales en Atlanta y Washington por
sus esfuerzos para revertir los
resultados en 2020 también se investigan
los documentos clasificados encontrados
en el domicilio del ex mandatario en
Florida